foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you that's wonderful we're taping
at the blue building and the guest of
honor tonight is Joshua monk who is a
Johns Hopkins Professor give a big hand
for him
and he's he's also the founder of a
really interesting online platform
magazine uh called persuasion and his
latest book is the identity trap a story
of ideas and Power in our time and I
don't know if anybody out there is an
academic or an intellectual a couple
people you know mildly raising their
hands uh one thing that's great about
this book is that if you believe in
ideas uh he really demonstrates and
documents that they matter which is kind
of nice to hear right
that you should hope so for sometimes
perhaps it'll be better if ideas
mattered less than they do that's right
okay but uh Yasha monk uh thanks for
coming out and let's start uh give me
the elevator pitch of uh the identity
trap well the elevator pitch is that uh
you know there's a new set of ideas
about race gender and sexual orientation
that has become really influential over
the last decade
and in the public debate about it I
think there's this weird tension where
on the right there's sometimes attacked
as destroying everything that's good and
holy and sometimes people invoke terms
like vocal critical race Theory to talk
about sensible things like recognizing
but there's still discrimination and
sexism and racism in our society or
wanting to teach kids about the history
of injustices in other states like
slavery and then on on on the left and
mainstream among many of my friends and
colleagues in response there's the sort
of suggestion that there's really
nothing to see here that certainly to
say your work is just to
um you know be nice and sensible and and
want to see reality and there's really
you know the the claim that the Norms
that organizations are run by United
States has changed it's just it's just
wrong and there's nothing ideologically
new about what's happening on the left
and so what I try to set out to do in
this book is to actually understand what
I think is a genuinely novel ideology an
ideology
it has an intellectual history of its
own that arose in universities in the
United States and other countries and
that then through a series of
interesting mechanisms came to have this
powerful influence on our society and I
think that those ideas deserve to be
taken seriously
um and when critiqued
um and so that's what I do and the first
part of the book I tell the the story of
where these ideas come from in the
academy let's let's start with that
um you call this new set of ideas uh
that have power that have you know kind
of taken over uh by your telling and I
think by many people's you know certain
the c-suites of certain types of
Corporations certainly the academy
increasingly different parts of American
life you call that the identity
synthesis can you describe what is the
identity synthesis yeah so first of all
we just need a damn term to refer to
this ideology you know like and you're
you you don't want to say oh this is
wopeness I think yeah all of those two
terms where we have are just very
politically charged right so socialism
some people love socialism probably most
people in this room don't like socialism
but we can all agree to call it
socialism right
um we need a term so we can discuss in a
serious and neutral way this body of
ideas and work is not going to do it
because it makes you sound like you're
an old man shouting at the clouds
okay so uh so I call it the identity
synthesis your age I'm ageist yes okay I
confess that's a dangerous place to be
in contemporary America it's the last
time I checked you know don't trust
anybody under 80 seems to be the
government
um long list our gerontocracy um
so so I think look these ideas are
fundamentally concerned with a role that
group identities do and should play in
our society and they are a synthesis of
different intellectual influences in
particular post-modernism
postcolonialism and critical race Theory
and so that's why I call it the identity
synthesis so call it whatever you want
call it the thing if we can just have a
word that allows us to have a serious
conversation okay let's let's start with
those kind of uh three tributaries how
are you defining post-modernism in this
context yeah so uh and I know I'm
Dangerous Ground here because Nick is a
deeply paid up postmodernist so he's
gonna he's gonna come at me from I go to
all the meetings yeah from the from the
it's going to come at me from a
post-modernist center yeah
um so uh look the first point to make
about intellectual history is that this
is not cultural Marxism
um so that is you know basically very
few people have tried to tell the story
of these ideas and the ones who have are
mostly
writing polemicists who've said this is
cultural Marxism and I have various
problems with that one of them is that
taking economic categories like social
class out of Marxism is a little bit
like saying you've taken the bat out of
baseball there's just not very much left
um you're describing both the New York
Yankees and the New York Mets but
um
and it's as wrong as a matter of
intellectual history if you think of
this as a form of cultural Marxism
you're not going to understand the
themes that dominate our politics today
so uh I think the starting point of this
ideology lies specifically with Michelle
Foucault
and Foucault is you know raised by
people who have his Grand theories about
how the world works first hegelian uh
teacher of his and Madam Marxist teacher
of his but he rejects those grand
narratives about the world including
both liberalism
um and uh Marxism
um he makes the argument that our belief
in any form of objective truth or our
belief in any form of real progress is
illusionary we might think we treat the
mentally ill or the criminals or other
people better in 1950s France when we
did 100 or 200 years ago that's all
Banker turns out to be wrong but we're
really influential point he makes is
about the nature of political power and
what he says is that you know when we
think of power when you ask uh you know
uh High School Civics student what power
is they might say well sort of top down
right it's like there's a state and we
pass some laws and then the police and
the bureaucracy is sort of implemented
in some way right it says no power in
the most important sense is we are
exercising power right now on stage by
the way we frame things by the way we
talk about things right power is this
discourse of process where everybody
exercises power over each other and as a
a result to oppose power is to recognize
these discourses to critique them but
you can never really make progress
because the moment you've dismantled one
discourse another one arises and that's
going to be a suppressive as the one
that went before I thank you for that
and you also quote of course uh leotards
uh very you know kind of foundational uh
definition of postmodernism as
incredulity toward meta-narratives
um the one thing and I this isn't about
post-modernism but it's interesting to
think about people like Foucault I've
talked and written about this from a
Libertarian perspective when you look at
his work particularly in the 70s and 80s
he got to a point where he was telling
his students in Paris to read mises and
Hayek and to look at liberalism uh
Etc so it's interesting to think about
him and also you know part of what you
do in the book which I think is really
important is that you also talk about
how these ideas have real Credence when
when Foucault was critiquing the
medicalization of everyday life and of
society you know at the same time that
somebody like Thomas saws was doing here
or the sociologists Irvin Goffman it was
a moment when people were like you know
what like Psychiatry and psychologizing
everything maybe that's a means of
social control it's not just a you know
like oh you know medical professionals
want to help people sometimes they're
putting people away you can argue that
it went too far or that itself was wrong
but there was a compelling understanding
of a lot of these big theories of
history and you know in France in the
60s Marxism certainly maybe not
liberalism but it had it had failed
right yeah and and I think you know my
probably my my favorite section in the
entire book comes at the end of part one
at the end of where I tell this
intellectual history and it's called
careful what you wish for
because I think that Foucault has all of
the tools to criticize the moment we're
in today
he says you know he's a homosexual or
somebody who's gay in our terms he's a
man who had sex with men he rejected
that term because he thought it was too
essentializing too simplifying too
constraining of a varieties of sexual
experiences his most famous metaphor is
that of a panopticon which he gets from
James Mill the idea that an efficient
prison would be one which the god stands
in the middle in a watchtower and he
might in theory be looking into any
prison cell at any one time and so as a
result he can punish prisoners when he
observes them breaking the law that's
the punishment part but most of the time
they self-discipline because they don't
know whether they're being observed or
not and so an anticipated obedience we
don't go close to the line and I think
that's a lot of what happens on social
media today right so so so so Foucault I
think would have hated a lot about this
political moment and when the story
really is and and you know we'll have to
read the book till you find out the
details of the story story more
precisely you need to buy the book yeah
but but right now pause the podcast or
get out your phone you're all allowed to
get out your phone because we didn't we
messed up and we don't have a book
seller tonight for this wonderful sold
out crowd but you can get out your phone
and and buy the book right now
um I I agree with you that Foucault
gives or postmodernism and particularly
a kind of faculty and it allows us to
critique many of the identities that are
being pushed in the power dynamics let's
shift to the next uh big tributary which
is post-colonial theory and you talk
about Edward Saeed uh New York's own
Columbia Zone what is postcolonialism
and how does that move into the identity
postcolonial Scholars two of the most
important ones both end up at Columbia
um
and they have uh this dilemma because
they're really attracted to
postmodernism infrastructuralism in
Foucault and so on because they're
giving them the tools to dismantle
Colonial discourses which Justified the
oppression of their countries right but
they're horrified by the apolitical
nature what they see is we a political
nature of Foucault but the fact that
they says there's no real progress to be
made right all you can do is to critique
with discourses when I had Noam Chomsky
on my podcast he said
um when he met Foucault in a famous
debate in the early 70s he was the most
immoral not immoral the most immoral man
I have ever met right and so they share
something about this quiet so they go to
work trying to re-politicize fuku and
there's two Kishore crucial moves here
but first is by Edward Saeed who says
all right
this this course is about the Orient
help to explain how colonial power was
exercised and continues to be exercised
um but the point is not just to
recognize that the point is to invert
those discourses what we want to do is
to use this course critique as a
political tool for actually shifting
power in the world and that becomes a
model for a lot of how politics works
today a lot of politics today is you
know if you're a feminist you might
fight for abortion rights and so on but
you're also got to do a lot of politics
by celebrating or critiquing the Barbie
movie by arguing what is or isn't
problematic well and and that's true
across not just families right across a
whole set of social movements that's a
lot of how we do politics today that is
saeed's politicized form of discourse
analysis that's his response to Foucault
and he also and I I think this is you
know incredibly meaningful that he
talked about that discourse is not just
political discourse it takes place at
the cultural level and so you know in
its kind of most abstruse form the
novels of Jane Austen or the Bronte
sisters is actually really kind of
softening the ground for a colonial a
colonialist understanding of the other
and making it okay to treat them in a
particular way which gives rise to
endless discussions of Barbie right as
as a meaningful cultural phenomenon
which I gotta say I you know my
background's in literary and cultural
studies so I'm all for that but
oftentimes well in a way if it's easy to
make fun of it but of course it's turned
out over the last 10 years that those
forms of politics are very effective so
in a way the victory of this form of
politics has been self-validating I
think 15 years ago it would have been
easy to Snead and said hahaha these
people think we're going to change the
world by saying but this movie is
problematic but but I think actually
that has turned out to be quite a
powerful way of doing politics there's
yeah there's a reason why Vacaville
called his Revel he named the peaceful
revolution in Czechoslovakia after a
rock band not after a political theorist
right so yeah so the next step is
Gayatri Spivak and she's saying look so
so so say it has been helpful but
there's still this problem that
um post-modernists have this critique of
identity categories and philosophically
speaking I buy this philosophically
speaking I agree that to say women have
something in common is overly
centralizing and wrong we should be
skeptical about that but you know what
Foucault and and Dolores really pissed
me off when they had this interview
where they say you know intellectuals
shouldn't speak for people anymore you
know the workers can speak for
themselves and speakers well that might
be true of white workers and Powers
who've had an education who have voting
rights and so on it might not be true of
the most disadvantage which of course
with sub-altern in places like Kolkata
and India where she's from somebody's
got to speak for them and I want to
speak for them
so how am I going to do that and she
comes up with this very paradoxical term
called strategic essentialism
philosophically speaking the the
critique of essentialist identity
categories is right but for strategic
political purposes we sometimes have to
act as forward we're true and sometimes
I choose therefore not to be
Universalist but an essentialist that
idea of strategic essentialism she
herself admits is paradoxical ends up
being super influential when you go to a
progressive space today people will say
well of course race is a social
construct something broadly speaking I
think is right right it's not actually a
biological reality you know but then
they'll go on to say that for all
intents and purposes we should think
about race as being the absolute
defining thing in society and we've
wanted to continue to be in certain ways
and we're going to split you up into
different groups depending on the color
of your skin and so on that is strategic
essentialism in a popularized perhaps
vulgarized form in action and then uh
critical race Theory how does that fit
into this
um so then you have the application of
these ideas to American law schools in a
tradition called critical legal studies
which is uh saying you know we used to
think that judges decide based on these
fine points of Doctrine but a lot of it
is the ideologies of a self-interest
it's a kind of postmodern critique of
the law and within that you start having
people who say well that's great but uh
critical legal studies itself has a big
blind spot and that's race
and so what does it look like when we
have that same analysis on race and the
key founder of this tradition is a man
called Derek Bell who does heroic work
in the 1960s
um working for the NAACP helping to
desegregate schools throughout the
American South but it comes to think of
that work as in many ways a mistake
um in some understandable ways he said
some of the students you know who we
argue on behalf of by the time that we
win the court case they've graduated so
then they don't get a benefit from the
school being integrated and so on but he
Embraces in his first big academic
article
um a theory which he acknowledges
explicitly comes from segregationist
Senators which is that all of her civil
rights lawyers claim to argue for their
clients but really were serving two
masters and my master they're really
serving is that or the integrationist
ideals but often don't help black people
and so therefore we should reject many
of the universal institutions of the
United States from Key parts of a
constitution to Brown versus Board of
Education perhaps separate but equal
would actually have been better because
there's no way of overcoming racism in
America because of a country by the year
2000 briefly before belt passes away
it's still as racist as it ever was the
only way we can make progress is to rip
those institutions up and make how you
treat it more explicitly depend on the
kind of group of which you are a part
and then
intersectionality is another part of
critical race Theory uh talk a bit about
that yeah so that's the last step um
Kimberly Crenshaw recognizes you know at
the beginning this idea of
intersectionality is what in the social
science as we know is an interaction
effect
um it's simply the recognition that the
Discrimination you might experience as a
black woman is not just an arithmetic
sum of a discrimination faced by uh
white women or black men it might go
beyond that and she has some great
examples of how there was the case in a
General Motors Factory in Michigan and
so on uh and that was an important
recognition
on a more kind of I I don't want to say
banal it's I'm being banal not Crenshaw
the idea that we have overlapping
identities that don't fully Define us
but kind of Stack together or whatever
you know we call ourselves you know
Americans you know Brooklyn Born
Catholic Jewish whatever that yeah
there's a kind of weird modern Bailey
going on there right where the mod were
kind of straightforward interpretation
of this is again what social scientists
know is interaction effect so knowing
that like it's not you know like you
have multiple identities and they both
help to determine who you are right and
that makes sense what becomes to that
idea and cruncher herself is somewhat
critical of that so it's not entirely to
be blamed for this is a much more
far-reaching set of ideas where you're
saying look if you're at a different
intersection of identities than me I
mean I really cannot fully understand
you
um and therefore to have effective
political action it's not a matter of me
listening to you and as having
solidarity and getting on the same page
it's a matter of saying look I don't
recognize I don't understand you but
you're more pressed than I am so I'm
going to defer to you in your judgment
about what to do and that becomes a very
common Progressive theme and then the
other idea is that since all forms of
Oppression are interlinked if you want
to be in good standing fighting against
a particular cause you have to fight
against all forms of Oppression at the
same time so you want to join a feminist
organization you also have to agree with
its view on uh housing against
development and you also have to agree
with its view on the Israel Palestine
conflict you also have to agree with its
view on trans issues and so on so forth
there's there's a fantastic moment in uh
2015 when Bernie Sanders was making a
campaign stop he was running for
president in Seattle and up to this
point Bernie was like you know he was a
class Warrior he believed that class was
the most important category and he
literally got upstaged by a couple of
black lives matter activists who almost
pushed him off the stage but he
retreated from the stage and then came
out with a new improved agenda which
through racial issues or black life
matters concerns on top of the race and
I always think of that when you talk
about kind of seeding ground to the
people who seem to have the moral High
Ground based on oppression yeah and so
so so so I think you know going back to
how should we understand the history of
these ideas I just don't think cultural
Marxism gives you very much about where
we are today I think the ideas we've
just talked through does give you a lot
of where we are today not every
quote-unquote World person not every
Progressive believes every single one of
those ideas but together they cost so
many themes of our left-wing politics
today right so it's skepticism about
objective truth and Universal values
from Michelle Foucault a Embrace of his
politicized form of discourse critique
as the key way of doing politics from
Saeed and embrace our strategic
essentialism which leads to things like
the progressive separatism we see in
schools of people being split into
different groups on the basis of race
that comes from uh Spivak
the skepticism about our ability to make
any kind of progress the permanence of
racism as well puts it and the Embrace
of these race sensitive public policies
of equity of equality that is Downstream
from Bell and when this interpretation
of intersectionality as we really can't
understand each other and so to make
common cause I have to defer to you if
you're on the more oppressed group that
I think helps to explain a lot of what's
happened over the last 10 years yeah
talk a little bit about what happened
how do you define I mean you've sketched
that out what are some of the concrete
effects you know say that we see in
corporations uh you know let's start
with that what yeah how does this stuff
play out in in a big Corporation well
let me give you a few examples
um you know what people go to usually on
this topic is kind of cancel culture
stuff
and I've written about this I've written
about Latino electrician in San Diego
who was fired from his job in the summer
of 2020 because somebody forcedly fought
with his hand dangling out of his truck
was the okay symbol which somehow was a
white supremacist symbol called some
idiots in 4chan and he lost his job was
the best job he ever had so those
stories are real and I worry about that
I worry about the fact that
sometimes I have lunch with friends or I
have lunch with you know CEOs or or
senators or important people and they
say the kind of thing we've been saying
was conversation and when they add of
course I would never say this publicly
and I worry about what that means for
our country for our trust in the
institution so all of that is real but
this is not a book about cancel culture
it's not a book about the stories
because I actually think this ideology
often has much more consequential impact
so let me give you two examples
one is a lady I spoke to and researching
for this book called Kyla Posey an
African-American educator in the suburbs
of Atlanta
who wants to request a particular
teacher for her the daughter who's I
believe in second grade
and the principles that show of course
send me over the name she did and then
was like ah well she kept deferring and
saying couldn't you teach it to choose a
different teacher
um and eventually calipers got annoyed
and said look what's going on why can't
I have my my the teacher but I think is
right for my kid and the principal said
well that's not the black class
now you might think this is straight up
racism you know segregation remark
itself this principle herself was a
black woman uh and a progressive and she
believed that for the right kind of uh
development of a child as a racial being
she has to be in an environment with a
lot of same race people even if she's
well integrated in her class uh that's
not good enough she's got to go to the
class where the other black kids are
right uh and and we see that take place
in many different contexts you know we
are recording this in New York City not
far from here
um at out in school they they have
embraced the idea that kids should think
of themselves as racial beings in order
to understand the world in the right way
at Bank Street School for kids on the
upper west side of Manhattan you take a
different subway line up there they do
racial Affinity groups and they
explicitly say not only that they want
the blackheads and Latino kids to to in
the spirit of strategic essentialism
have a form of ethnic solidarity which
is understandable at least
um they say the white kids need to own
the European Heritage need to Define
themselves more strongly as white
um Europe of course is a uh historically
unified continent
there's been any wars in Europe recently
can I ask I mean you know in the Marxist
libertarian I'm not only you know I'm
very a coherent I'm a Libertarian I'm a
post-modernist and I'm prone to
marxianic class analysis is that a good
thing that the children of the Elites in
New York are being taught completely
stupid things because it makes the rest
of us and our kids who may not have
quite the same number of advantages just
outperform them in the real world well
no because actually What It Takes now to
succeed in many Elite institutions is to
have been habituated into paying lip
service to these ideas in an uncritical
way
um you know my students who I teach are
wonderful students and they're very
thoughtful but they do worry and Hopkins
down in Baltimore yes yeah um but they
do worry and complain but some of the
professors they have
um you know it's very clear that you
have to agree with the politics in order
to get a good grade
um so you know but the thing I really
worry about back to you know bologna or
whatever the first uh University was
Perhaps Perhaps you know but but here's
my real worry which is that everything I
know from history and social science
teaches me that
um how you define yourself is very
context dependent there's many different
ways of defining yourself
but once you define Yourself by a
particular group and you see this again
and again in social science experiment
if I get my students to debate whether
or not a hot dog is a sandwich the kids
who think about the hot dog is a
sandwich discriminate against the kids
who think where the hot dog is not a
sandwich so if you tell those kids we're
going to put you in a white group we're
gonna lie to you about white privilege
and how bad white people are they might
be uncomfortable and I don't care
they're uncomfortable you can be
uncomfortable times in your education
that's fine but if you actually succeed
in making them think the most important
thing about me is that I'm white a few
of them might become great ibrahamex
candy style anti-racists who want to
denounce White Privilege most of them
are going to become white supremacists
and that's actually my concern let's
talk a little bit about your identity
and then I want to talk about how we get
out of this and then we'll open it up to
uh questions from the audience
you write at the beginning in the uh
it's not quite the first chapter but
it's kind of the beginning you say all
four of my grandparents were sent to
prison for their communist beliefs
during the 1920s or 30s it's an
interesting and why would they be proud
that I'm a Libertarian Speak Easy yeah
that's you know so it's like this is
progress right you know to thank you
Hegel
um but
um you know you you were born in Germany
you grew up there and then you came to
the United States can you give us a
quick capsule biography
and leave the sex stuff out that's in
your book the identity trap we don't
need to go through that now
all the details um
so yeah my my I mean you know my my
ancestors went the wrong place at the
wrong time for a large number of
generations
um and uh my my grandparents were born
in Shettles in uh what today's Ukraine
um and for understandable reasons they
uh uh you know became Communists because
in their context
um that's the ideology that promised
falsely as it turns out uh a form of
solidarity across religious in other
groups right something where the workers
of the world would unite and the fact
that they were Jewish and the neighbors
were not wouldn't mean that they might
suffer pogromes
um they went prison in the 30s for
advocating those police survived for
Holocaust and the Soviet Union came back
to Poland to help build up the Communist
Regime and when lo and behold the
Communist Regime turned on them and
threw them out and through my parents
who were 18 20 out as well and so I
ended up uh growing up in in Germany
going to what year were you born 1982
okay so you you don't really remember
uh you know pre-fall of the wall no I
have a memory of a Berlin Wall falling
but oddly I have a memory watching this
on TV in a house where we didn't live in
until I was until after 1989 so it's
clearly something's wrong well it's all
a simulation so you know but that's
bowed your yard yeah I think you know
that those weird explosives said the
wall how did you
um you uh how did you go from you know
that to uh being who you are today
um I I knew that I wanted to study
outside of Germany
um in part because I wanted an adventure
internationally in part because uh you
know I England had better universities
and I was attracted to that and part
because growing up Jewish and Germany I
experienced some of the social norms
that I think later made me allergic to
some of the stuff in the United States
um so you know when I was born in 1982 I
was about 30 000 Jews left in Germany
Island was a little bit more after 1989
1990 but most of the people I grew up
with had never met a Jew and so to them
you know hours the whole uh
representation of their complicated past
and depending how it felt about the past
they felt about me and so sometimes I
got anti-Semitism and so on and it was
unpleasant but you could kind of deal
with it I think it was screw you you
know there's nothing wrong with me but I
also got this really creepy filo
semitism a lot of the time where people
try to prove to me uh how much we love
the Jews or like tell me that Hebrew is
a beautiful language at the time you
know Germans no beautiful languages
I mean but compared to German surely
Hebrew is a beautiful language
um at the time this was the last
controversial statement they they would
tell me how much they love the movie the
movies of Woody Allen
[Laughter]
um anyway so I think that's actually
part of when I saw some similar norms
and Customs uh entering the social space
where I was in the States was suddenly
rather than being the representative of
victims I became the representative of
perpetrators I thought I hated being
treated in this way and I don't want to
treat others why did you come to the
United States because I love New York
yeah and then I basically never fully
hey yes cheer for New York
um and then I like came here and I did a
year at Colombia and I didn't take any
classes just passed away I didn't take
any class of Spivak I guess I should
have done
um and then I ended up doing my PhD at
Harvard and teaching other places and
I've always like half lived in New York
but I never actually had a professional
reason to be in New York what what do
you like about New York
um I think a lot of
what I loved at the time and still love
is the crime
it's it's a sense it's a high rent
um they're quite magnificent I saw
comedian the other day who said you know
stop complaining about the higher ends
you really have to do something about it
if you think the rents are too high go
stab somebody
if someone stabs me I wouldn't I
wouldn't complain say thank you for your
service
um that if it's not my joke sadly
um no it's it's it's that I think in New
York you you you you you could at a
certain time and you still can not be
defined by who you are I think there's
something about New York that celebrates
influences from all over the world and
encourages people to be true to that to
be proud of their cultural heritage and
yet there are so many different ways in
which cultures meet I I guess what I'm
saying in the terms of one of the
chapters in the later part of a book
where I talk about this topic is that
New York is the world capital of
cultural appropriation right and I love
that about it no uh well let's talk
about that and um and you know move into
how do we get out of the situation we're
and I think a lot of people you talk in
the book A lot of people are pessimists
um certainly you know people on the
right have their own issues but people
on the left are pessimists they can't
acknowledge progress on any level I
think the right also does that in
different ways how do we get out of the
kind of broad-based cultural Funk that
we're in that you know cultural
appropriation is everywhere and it's bad
that identity is simultaneously
completely protein and so we we're all
borderline personalities but then we
also have these essential fixed
qualities that we means we can never
communicate with one another
well I think a lot of it is where we
have to win the argument and and to win
the argument you have to take the idea
seriously and actually understand them
and then argue against them right so I
was joking about cultural appropriation
but I think it's an important topic so I
have so mostly we've talked about part
one of the book was about intellectual
history in part two I explain how these
ideas come to be powerful and then in
part three I criticize the main
applications to areas from free speech
to raise sensitive public policies but
let's take cultural appropriation as one
example right there's come to be this
General suspicion this General taboo
about Mutual cultural influence or
there's something potentially dangerous
and unjust about it and I get where that
comes from because there's some examples
of so-called cultural appropriation that
were clearly unjust like white musicians
stealing the songs of black musicians in
the 50s and 60s when they couldn't have
big careers the problem is that the term
of cultural appropriation fails to
express what was wrong about that
situation or how we could have had a
remedy what was wrong is not this
musical style still gaining an influence
and gaining a broader audience was
beautiful what was wrong was the
horrible discrimination outright
discrimination with those black
musicians suffered which meant that they
couldn't travel across the South perform
in many concert Halls be signed by Major
record labels that was that's what was
unjust and that's what we should have
done in order to remedy that to tackle
that problem I give the example of a
fraternity party at Baylor University
with the uh unpleasant name of Cinco de
drinko
um
in which you had kids mostly why turn up
some in ponchos and sombreros others in
construction vests and Maze outfits
now this is clearly offensive
but according to the concept of cultural
appropriation you can't actually pick
out what philosophers call the
wrong-making feature of this situation
because from the perspective of cultural
appropriation the kids who turned up in
ponchos did something horrible but the
kids who turned up in May's outfits
didn't do anything wrong because the
maze outfit is not part of Mexican
culture it's if anything I guess part of
French culture so they weren't
procreating the culture right that's
clearly absurd what was wrong here is
that we students were trying to send the
message but Latinos are less than but
all the good for us to be Maids or
construction workers it was something to
be poked fun at and so we should defend
Mutual cultural influence as one of the
beautiful things about New York is one
beautiful things about America and not
give in to this idea that there should
be a general poll of Suspicion on ways
to influence each other culturally how
would you deal with that you know let's
say you're a college administer let's
say everything goes wrong for you and
you end up a college administrator
country and got back to Germany or
Ukraine or I would I would rather be and
please if I ever become a Dean uh quote
this line back to me and you know take
me out in an Alleyway and shoot me
um I would rather be a general you know
a regional manager of Trader Joe's than
the Deeds are the dean of social science
at least you can fire and hire people
you know as a Dean you have no power to
do anything and everybody hates you it's
the worst job in the world in a in a
pragmatic sense like how how do you deal
with a situation like that if you you
know on a college campus Baylor is you
know it's a good school uh it's a
Christian school it's a Baptist School
how do you explain to people like maybe
that's not the greatest idea
I mean I think uh I don't know in this
particular case it depends on the
particular rules of the student handbook
and so on I assume if it didn't break
any technical rules
um I think that this is something that
students can also handle among
themselves I think it's perfectly
appropriate that there would be some
kind of social repercussions for the
kids who took part in that but a lot of
people tell them hey you did something
terrible
um I'm not sure that uh you know this is
something that the administration needs
to get involved it's one of the strange
things that students who claim to be
Rebels today
the First Act of rebellion is to call a
college administrator that's not
something that anybody in the 60s would
afford you should do right but but let
me perhaps speak because I feel like I
gave a slightly narrow answer to your
question earlier you know here's what
here's a broadest level at which to
argue against this ideology I talked to
you through some of the main themes of
of the identity synthesis
um but you can also step back and boil
it down to what I think as three main
philosophical propositions
and those are number one
that
um the key prism to understand the world
is uh race gender and sexual orientation
that is the thing you always have to
look at in any situation to understand
what's going on
it's fascinating when I was in grad
school studying literature from the late
80s to the mid 90s the prisms were race
class and gender everything was we're
going to look at the race class in
general implications of stuff and it's
fascinating class kind of dropped out of
that yeah sometimes people pay lip
service to it but when you talk look at
what they actually pay attention to and
actually talk about it's very very rare
nobody wants the same is true of
religion sometimes people say religion
but religion only matters when it's
correlated with race right so religion
matters in the Muslim context United
States because Muslim people by and
large are non-white in the United States
of course there are white Muslims as
well but that's sort of How It's seen
right
um but it doesn't matter in context
where it's not correlated with a
minority ethnic group
um so that's number one right that's how
you have to see the world number two is
um
Universal principles like the
Constitution the Bill of Rights like
like the 14th Amendment like uh uh even
some civil rights legislation is
actually meant to pull the wool over
your eyes it is meant to make it easier
to cloak and to justify the continuation
of various forms of racial sexual and so
on dominance and discrimination and that
is why America today is as homophobic as
sexist as racist as whatever is as it
was in the past that's the second key
claim and then the third claim is that
therefore since we haven't made progress
under these Universal values you have to
rip them up and substitute it with a
regime where how we treat each other and
how the state treats all of us will
always explicitly depend on the group of
which we're a part now I think there's
very good philosophically liberal I'm
going to say to bridge The Space Between
You Libertarians and me squishy you know
Center left liberal
um there's a very good response each of
these claims and that response is number
one
that of course race gender and sexual
orientation matter in some context so of
course there's context where that's very
important including in the United States
today in general but it is not the only
thing that matters instead of looking at
the world with just one prism as Marxist
did just looking at class and now we're
doing just with these kind of identity
categories you have to let the situation
teach you how to interpret it we
shouldn't in the words of Jonathan hate
be mono maniacal in how we perceive the
world yes race gender sexual orientation
matters yes class matters yes religion
matters yes our individual attributes
matters how we act matters what our
aspirations are matter you have to let
the situation teach you Robin D'Angelo
the sort of worst popularizer of all of
these ideas has once said that
um every time that a white person
interrupts a black person by bringing
the entire apparatus of white supremacy
to bear on them
that makes me think that Robin D'Angelo
doesn't have any black friends
because of course
of course sometimes between certain
contacts it was certainly true in the
19th century in all kinds of contexts
but it's not true if your best friends
will argue about politics and interrupt
each other over time then that's a sign
of equality right secondly
it is profoundly untrue that the
universal liberal values we've been
talking about have failed to allow us to
make progress you know Frederick
Douglass
called free speech for dread of tyrants
recognizing that it allowed people to
say awful things in his day but it also
allowed abolitionists when they were
very unpopular to fight for their ideals
yeah he also gave a great speech what to
the slave as the Fourth of July but
called the Constitution a glorious
Freedom document he said you all are
hypocrites sitting here celebrating the
Constitution celebrating the Declaration
of Independence saying isn't it lovely
when there's slavery in our country but
he didn't say therefore rip up those
values he said so if you mean it live up
to them this document is glorious it
hasn't become reality and in that sense
liberalism or libertarianism or whatever
ism is a progressive Creed right we're
not saying everything is great we're
saying we have the right principles now
it's time to live up to them and to be
aspiration to live up to them from
Frederick Douglass to ABRA Lincoln to
Martin Luther King and others is part of
what has allowed us to make progress and
by the way it's offensive to say we
haven't made any progress not offensive
to us wonderful Americans living today
but offensive to the Americans in the
past who've suffered much much worse
discrimination to say that Marcus as
homophobic today as in the past is
absurd when in the lifetime of eunuch
and me and the generous had to leave her
talk show because she admitted having a
girlfriend right it's just absurd and so
first how she was canceled because she's
a pain to work with yes that's probably
that's you know of all the forms of
cancellation being a pain to work with I
feel like is a fair one
um
the so what do we do well we we we we
double down on trying to live up to
these values that is the the right
response and that is what uh you know a
huge swath of Americans actually believe
and that by the way is the philosophy
that can make you win against the
generally dangerous racist and far-right
populists and so on who are a very very
real threat in our politics today
all right we're gonna stop there
all right uh this has been the recent
interview with Nick Gillespie I want to
thank tonight's guest Joshua monk the
book is the identity trap a story of
ideas and Power in our time thanks so
much thank you
[Applause]